we've been hearing denials from various
Russians about particular aspects of
possible Trump Russia collusion Putin
says Russia didn't do this
Sergei his lyac says Russia didn't do
that but we now have confirmation an
admission really from the Kremlin that
indeed Donald Trump's personal lawyer
Michael Cohen reached out to them during
the 2016 presidential election looking
for help for this business project in
Russia that he and Felix aider seemed
interested in pursuing which they
believed as I told you earlier this week
Felix aider and Michael Cohen
were working together on a Moscow Trump
tower that they seemed to believe would
be really useful in helping Donald Trump
to become president of the United States
not only is this huge because it's the
first of what will probably be multiple
confirmations we received from Russia
about different contact and attempted
contact between Associates of Donald
Trump and Russian associates it's also
huge because Michael Cohen was
supposedly a nobody in this entire thing
Michael Cohen figured Bigley for lack of
a better term in Christopher Steele's
Trump Russia blackmail dossier but
everybody involved with Trump including
Cohen himself kept telling us oh no no
Michael Cohen he has nothing to do with
anything that's Russia related period
and the truth is and we're learning more
about it almost weekly the truth is
Cohen has had huge involvement in what's
going on with Russia and now we even
have the Kremlin admitting it President
Vladimir Putin's spokesman Dmitry Peskov
told reporters in Moscow yesterday that
yeah they received an email from Trump's
attorney Michael Cohen which he oddly
enough sent to the press offices general
email address Peskov said hey listen
they get emails like that oh oh not like
that but they get all sorts of emails
all the time and that the Kremlin didn't
reply to it I'm going to talk a little
bit more in a minute or two about why I
think that that's interesting that the
Kremlin would even choose to admit this
Michael Cohen Trump's lawyer has also
since admitted that yeah he
working on that real estate proposal
with Felix Seder exactly as the
Washington Post alleged exactly as the
New York Times alleged over the weekend
there will be people who say David this
is no big deal
this means absolutely nothing and I kind
of agree and that's why this is so
meaningful contextually this is a very
minor admission from Russia right this
is a an admission that it's it's so
small yeah we got an email from Michael
Cohen but we didn't even respond it's so
minor that it clearly is a calculated
admission from Russia to slightly stir
the pot and start to create even more
chaos and if you understand the Russian
playbook on geopolitics which we've
talked about that's a top priority you
cede chaos any way that you can and
that's why when you hear this and you
say this is such a minor admission
that's exactly the point
it's create a little bit of confusion
wait why is the Kremlin even admitting
to this they have really no need to
admit to this it's all about seeding
chaos it is interesting though because
the Kremlin has been unwilling to
confirm anything with regards this whole
Trump Russia scandal exact certainly if
they did hack the US presidential
election they're not going to turn
around and admit to it then now and
there's been a number of other things
that are a lot more benign that they're
not willing to confirm as welcome Souter
so maybe they look at this as just a big
nothing burger or maybe they just look
at it as such an easy thing to prove
otherwise if they were to deny it
because you know it's just an email that
could turn up anywhere that maybe one
aspect of it the other aspect is
whatever the bottom line objective truth
is about Trump Russia collusion and
hopefully someday we'll know it right I
don't know Russia doesn't really win by
acting in a way that would potentially
accelerate an impeachment of Donald
Trump if that would actually happen
Russia wins from general disorder when
you consider Vladimir Putin's desire to
have Russia taken more seriously at the
geopolitical level and to be framed
compared to other world leaders as
particularly sly clever competent
whatever they win from general disorder
the
win by the us being chaotic from the
White House being a madhouse that's
exactly what's going on and the more
that the u.s. is consumed by infighting
and dysfunction in the White House the
better it is for Russia and even an
impeachment trial against Donald Trump
could be there to their benefit too
because that doesn't sue some chaos yeah
especially if they're unable to get
whatever they wanted out of a perceived
deal with the Trump people because he's
just too impotent at this point and
unable to push for whatever he wants his
policy the process of impeachment is
part of the chaos that benefits Russia
the possible removal of Trump from the
White House that's not actually that
much in Russia's interest so really
there if you are Russia and you want to
have a role to play in the chaos that's
going on your interest is in extending
the chaos for as long as possible and
making it as crazy as you possibly can
they certainly were opposed to Hillary
Clinton in favor Donald Trump but in the
last go-around it seemed like they were
more in support of Barack Obama winning
them Mitt Romney because Romney called
them are our biggest threat because
geopolitical foe geopolitical foe so you
know they're not playing for one
political party or another is really are
just to insu chaos it has nothing to do
with party whatsoever I think that's a
key point the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership